[MUSIC PLAYING]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
The Music and Theater Arts--
they inspire all of MIT with
new ideas, new experiences,
and just makes them better
people, and better scientists,
better engineers--
just better communicators.
What's really exciting
about MIT is it
has this unique opportunity
for people like me,
who are passionate about
so many different types
of things, where I don't
have to be a music major
to participate in
high level music.
Once we start
rehearsal, I completely
forget that I have
a PSET due tomorrow,
or that I have an
exam in three days.
It's just an experience that
completely takes you away.
And I think that's what
makes it so enjoyable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They sound amazing, and it made
me forget that they are not
majoring in, necessarily--
[LAUGHING]
--music.
So that's pretty amazing, the
high level that they have here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They're working
very hard in school.
To take time for music is
not easy for many of them,
and yet they bring
their best game to it.
And that makes it a
pleasure to work on things.
94-- winds who have
these 16th note
figures, those should
not be articulate.
Through arts at MIT, I've been
able to interact with literally
my heroes, musically--
Jamshied Sharifi, Chick Corea,
Anat Cohen, Miguel Zenón,
Don Byron.
(SINGING) We're gonna
have a funky good time.
These students are
so interested in life
and trying so hard to
figure out what they can do,
and discovering skills.
It's great to be part of that.
It gives me energy every year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There are concerts here that
I would never have imagined
being able to be a part of--
the Jacob Collier
experience, going
to Puerto Rico with Miguel,
the Clarinet Summit.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is typical Fred.
I was just walking down the
Infinite Corridor one day,
and I just happened
to run into him.
And he says, oh, hey, Eran, I
have this idea that-- and what
are you doing on May 11?
And I look at my calendar, and
I said, yeah, I think I'm free.
He's like, great,
because we're going
to do this Clarinet Summit.
It's going to be amazing.
I hope you can play.
I was like, OK,
sounds good, thanks.
This whole thing came
to me in a dream,
and I can't believe
it actually happened.
It hasn't happened yet,
but we've gotten this far.
So this is very, very cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's been more and more of
a commitment throughout MIT
to support artistic endeavors,
even the wildest and most
ambitious ones.
And there's been
people like Fred,
who are willing to be
ambitious, to come up
with a wild and amazing idea
that then comes to life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fred is MIT's Energizer Bunny.
He works harder than all of us.
Fred, if you're watching
this, go to bed.
Seriously, he should sleep more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, good.
I have a rehearsal pedagogy that
I'm going to suggest for you.
And then I'm going to leave,
and then I'm going to come back.
Fred really is a force
to be reckoned with.
He doesn't stop, he keeps going.
And his brain is always active.
And he's got so many ideas,
and he's just brilliant.
And he loves people,
and he loves music.
And he is a great
collaborator too.
I think I maybe went
too far the other way.
So I have to bring
it back, but--
It's better than the ink,
that's all I can say.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The man has drive, and
he is so incredible
to watch and work with.
And the passion he
exudes is amazing.
Is there time?
Could we have one
hour on Friday?
Do you have time?
See if you could figure it out.
If you can't, we might
not need a whole hour.
But I think if we could run
the piece a thousand times
Friday, that would be good.
He's respectful
of the past, but I
think he's got a
vision for the future,
for himself and for the program.
And I think he works tirelessly
towards those visions.
The students who have had
the chance to work with Fred,
and FJE, and MITWE, are working
with the musical presence
that's as powerful as Herb was.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's profound.
I know it was for me
and still is for me.
And I think it will be
for all these students,
regardless of the paths they
take, whether it's in music
or not.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We hired Fred from his previous
job, which was as a high school
wind leader.
We thought he was just the
most top flight candidate
we could have imagined.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
He's been willing to
take chances on things
that seem crazy at the outset.
Getting Jacob to come for
a week, I was like, Fred,
you're not going to
get that to happen.
And now he's done it twice.
[VOCALIZING]
Just watching him
conduct on stage,
you think, wow, I want to have
that level of appreciation
for music, for such a
breadth of music too.
He does so many interesting
things, and he loves all of it
dearly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
He's definitely someone who's
very humanitarian oriented
and really wants to
make a social impact
and bring the
community together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fred's guests have
been a diverse crowd.
And his idea of where he
would like to be involved
has really pushed
in the direction
of understanding other
cultures that are marginalized.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When the hurricane first hit,
he helped organize a fundraiser
with MIT Wind Ensemble
and the different groups
he does to send
supplies to Puerto Rico.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The whale song was one
of Fred's wacky ideas.
So the idea is that maybe this
baby whale, or mother and baby,
are caught in the net,
and it's horribleness.
And then this is sort
of a requiem for them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When Fred first
introduced the idea
of playing with whale sounds,
I was kind of confused.
And when we performed it
in front of the audience,
you could tell that
they were feeling
what we were trying to convey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fred's a good drummer, and
I've played with him a lot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The kids in the band get a
big kick out of the times
when he plays because they
don't get to actually hear him
very often.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
He knows how to lift musicians
and make them want to shine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
He just has such a warm,
inspiring character.
And so he knows how
to make people relax,
and he knows how to push people,
for them to do their best.
I'd like you to emote more.
I'd like you to-- for
lack of a better phrase--
sell it musically
more, by exaggerating
the emotional moments, via
dynamics and your soul.
I started out as
one of his mentors
when he was 14 years old.
I was a big deal to him.
And I told the MIT Wind
Ensemble the other night
when I rehearsed with
them, at this point
he's one of my mentors.
He's a big deal to me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fred single-handedly got
me through undergrad,
either indirectly
or directly, by just
encouraging me to make music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Every time I talk to him, I
get so much joy because he
genuinely cares
about his students,
and he really works
hard to make sure
that we're also just doing
well as human beings outside
of music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fred is also very
mindful of challenges
that other people
are dealing with.
And he would check
in on me all the time
and say, how can I help?
What can I do?
And honestly, having his support
when I was going through a lot
was incredible.
And I know I'm not
the only student who's
had that experience with Fred.
So I've had lots of
teachers over the years,
I've worked with lots
of different people.
And I do have to say that
Fred Harris is perhaps
the most inspirational
person I've ever worked with.
[APPLAUSE]
A great human being,
a great family man,
a great colleague to all of
us in the music education
community, and a
compassionate and caring
teacher for, now, thousands
and thousands of students.
He's very genuine about
what he's expressing.
I think Fred is a genius.
Sensitive, but also
extremely smart and witty.
The unique thing
about a Fred rehearsal
is how much time they spend
actually playing the music
and how little time he
expends explaining it.
Just a great mentor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
How is that water phone?
I heard it.
Yeah, I like it.
It's pretty cool, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll double
check, but I think so.
OK.
Thank you for checking.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good night.
[LAUGHING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]